good morning heck it's tuesday two major
developments first the anthropocene
reviewed book has a cover and today i
want to show it to you and also talk
about how book covers happen or at least
how they've happened for my books the
anthropocene reviewed is my sixth book
but because of reprints and foreign
editions and so on i've had over a
hundred covers for my books some of
which i didn't particularly care for
some of which i absolutely adore and
then there are some that are just
wondrous in their strangeness like the
swedish cover of turtles all the way
down
and cover design is often a fraught and
complex experience for authors not just
because a cover is the first part of the
book the reader will see but also
because the cover design is often the
first time
anyone has responded artistically to the
book plus the cover comes at a time in
the publishing process when i feel
exceptionally exposed and nervous i mean
the cover designer is often the first
person i don't know to read the book
now some authors have almost complete
control over their covers others have
little to no say in the process
i've been lucky always to have a voice
in the conversation at least for my u.s
covers thanks to my editor julie strauss
gable who has been my editor since my
first book was published 16 years ago
and for the anthropocene review the
cover began with julie and i talking we
talked about the artwork of hiroyuki doi
and my circle drawings and road trips
and microorganisms
and the bonneville salt flats and
sunsets and we also discussed our
favorite book designers like these days
book covers have to work both as
physical objects and as two inch high
thumbnails and i
love the designs of grace han because
they're bold and legible but they also
find a way to be
really human even vulnerable which is
what i want the book to be
so then julie was like i'll ask grace if
she's interested and she was
and she read the book and then developed
a few possible covers and i was
immediately drawn to one that showed
interweaving bands of color i was
reminded of joseph albert's color
studies where perception of color
changes depending on proximity to other
colors like this brown and this brown
appeared different to me but they are in
fact the same brown
and grace's paths of shifting color felt
like a visual expression of what i have
tried to write about in the anthropocene
reviewed how perspective shapes
so-called reality
and how forces big and small shape the
paths we end up sharing you can read a
short interview with grace in the
comments below but one thing she told me
was
i like to brainstorm while thinking of
someone who would most need the book i
am working on
for the anthropocene reviewed i think i
was that someone
i lost a close friend last year and
recently found myself wound up in the
stresses of pandemic life
simply put i was becoming cynical and
losing my ability to be present
when i read the introduction i was
gripped by the idea of pathways and
labyrinths and it stayed with me
throughout the rest of the book
because each essay felt like a path i
personally loved the essay on sunsets
because i felt it best described what
this book encourages me to do
take off my armor of cynicism and love
the beauty
that surrounds us so i gravitated toward
this idea of
intertwining paths and journeys lit by
the colors of the sunset
i hope the imperfect paths and hand
lettering echoes the imperfect but bold
paths we all travel
for me that's exactly what grace's cover
achieves it finds a way to be beautiful
and sincere without being maud when
it renders the sunset in the way i hope
to render it in that essay and it says
so much about what i hope the book will
be for its readers
i never really know what i want my
covers to look like the truth is i'm
incredibly lucky to be able to publish
it all let alone have brilliant
designers respond to my work but when i
saw
this cover i immediately thought oh
there it is the cover of the
anthropocene reviewed
and it became real to me i hope you love
it as much as i do and thank you so so
much to grace han for bringing it to
life the anthropocene review book comes
out on may 18th
and is available for pre-order now hank
i will see you on friday
here's the second major development